COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
we take a Compute Engine's
disk options for a spin.
Will their performance
leave us dizzy?
Stay tuned to find out.
When we talk about the "cloud,"
we tend to over index on things
like "compute" and "network,"
because quite frankly,
those are the things
that the "cloud" can do,
which the machine sitting
under your desk can't.
But with this focus, we tend
to forget something-- disks.
See, all that data you're
processing has to go somewhere.
And on Google Cloud Platform,
choosing the right type of disk
can make a huge difference
in the performance
of your application.
As such, let's take a look
at what type of disk options
are available and what their
performance looks like.
In Google Cloud Platform,
there are two main types
of disks-- local SSDs
and persistent disks.
Local SSDs are pretty
much what you'd expect,
drives that are
physically attached to
your virtual machine instance.
So when your VM spins down,
so does the data on the disk.
Persistent disks,
on the other hand,
are network storage devices
that act like a local storage
device with the
upside being that they
can persist even after your
VM stops and can even be
reattached to a new VM later.
And on the persistent
disk side, it's
worth noting that there's
two flavors, standard
and SSD, which behave
pretty much the same
except one is a lot
faster than the other.
Now, I understand that every
application is different
and has unique
needs, which might
make you choose one of these
options from the other.
But from my perspective, I
care about the best performance
for the best price.
To get a sense of this,
a small benchmark tests
shows us how each of
the disks performed,
measuring the number of
IO operations per second
per gigabyte of data.
Directly, we see a
very clear trend.
Local SSDs outperform both
types of persistent disks, which
completely makes sense, given
that local SSDs are physically
connected to the VM.
So we should see better perf.
This graph also shows us that as
far as the persistent disks go,
the SSD variant outperforms
their standard counterparts
quite easily.
But this doesn't really
tell the full story,
which is why I like to break
up the graph between throughput
and IOPS to help figure out
what disk is the best use
case for what
application scenario.
For example, boot disk
volumes and bulk storage
are great matches for
standard persistent disks
because they require very
low IOPS and low throughput.
Basically, you just want
to occupy the cheapest,
most reliable space available.
Likewise, streaming
IO works best
with standard persistent disks
since the cost per throughput
is generally a little better.
Now, relational databases
tend to be more IOPS heavy.
And while smaller
instances might
be able to run on
standard PD, you really
want your production
deployments running
on some sort of SSD flavor disk.
File servers mostly
fall in the SSD-PD camp,
since they can either be
more streaming or more
transactional, depending on
what the clients are doing.
And finally, high
performance scratch disks
tend to perform
best on local SSD,
which is also an ideal
use case for things
like Hadoop deployments.
Now, it's worth reiterating that
each of the three disk options
have various types
of configurations
that can change how they perform
under different workloads,
which is why we've got
more videos on the way.
So make sure you check out the
rest of the "Cloud Performance
Atlas" content, because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]